>>> A FORMER HEAD COACH CLAIMS
HE WAS OFFERED MONEY TO LOSE
GAMES.
BUT HIS ACCUSATIONS GO MUCH
FURTHER.
HE SAID A PATTERN OF
RACIALIZATION ARE A PATTERN
AMONG THE NFL.
THE LEAGUE IS DOWN TO JUST ONE
BLACK COACH.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABAR HAS SPENT
HALF A CENTURY CALLING OUT WHAT
HE SEES AS INJUSTICE, AND HE
WRITES, WHAT TOOK SO LONG?
I'M NOT REFERRING SPECIFICALLY
TO FLORES' LAWSUIT BUT TO MAKE
PUBLIC THE RACISM INHERENT IN
THE NFL.
KAREEM ABDUL-JABAR JOINS ME NOW.
THANK YOU, KAREEM, FOR BEING
WITH US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FLORES
LAWSUIT.
FIRST THE ALLEGATIONS MUCH
RACISM.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS BEHIND THE
LACK OF BLACK PEOPLE IN
MANAGEMENT AND HEAD COACHING
POSITIONS IN THE NFL?
>> I THINK THAT IT HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH FAMILIARITY AND JUST
HAVING IT GO ON THE WAY IT'S
BEEN GOING ALONG BECAUSE THE NFL
MAKES A LOT OF MONEY AND THEY
DON'T SEE THE NEED TO OPEN THE
DOORS TO MINORITIES.
>> THERE ARE PROBLEMS THROUGHOUT
INDUSTRY, THROUGHOUT COMPANIES
OF A LACK OF DIVERSITY AT THE
VERY TOP OF THE CORPORATE
PYRAMID.
WHAT'S PARTICULARLY NOTICEABLE
AND WHICH YOU POINT OUT IN YOUR
ARTICLE IS THAT IT'S NOT AS IF
THERE IS A DEARTH OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES IN THE NFL, THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE -- MOST OF THE
PLAYERS ARE BLACK AND HAVE
EXPERIENCE WORKING ON A FOOTBALL
TEAM AND KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE,
AND YOU WOULD THINK IN THAT
INDUSTRY WOULD BE EASIER TO HAVE
PEOPLE MOVING UP FROM AFTER
THEIR PLAYING YEARS, MOVE UP
THROUGH MANAGEMENT.
>> ALMOST HAD -- ALMOST 60% OF
THE PLAYERS IN THE NFL ARE BLACK
OR SOME OTHER PERSON OF COLOR,
AND THE FACT THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY OF THEM THAT STOOD ON THE
SIDELINES, TONY DUNGY AS AN
EXAMPLE WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
GUIDING THE FOOTBALL TEAM TO
WINNING.
WHERE DOES THE GUILT LIE IN NOT
BEING ABLE TO HIRE MORE PEOPLE
OF MINORITY STATUS?
THE NBA HAS TRIED IT AND IT'S
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL FOR THEM.
COACHING, ASSISTANT COACHING,
PEOPLE WORKING IN THE FINANCIAL
ASPECTS OF THE TEAM, ALL THESE
ARE CONSIDERED CONTROVERSIAL AND
THE NBA CONTINUES TO THRIVE AND
ATTRACT A BIGGER AND BIGGER
AUDIENCE.
SO I DON'T THINK THE NFL HAS A
FO